thanks Valentin and hi everyone this is
Bernie and in this part of the tutorial
we'll be talking about deep
probabilistic model just to recap what
we learn what we've learned so far the
model method such as neural network
models struggle with strategic
forecasting problem because normally it
will require a large amount of data for
the neural network to be reliable its
range in this case it's better to use a
classical top 10 source model on the
other hand your efforts shines where you
have a large traditional time series
especially when each of the temps trees
only have a limited amount of
information for example as you can see
here the first time series has no time
and demand information at all which is a
complete costar problem and the second
one has only a small amount of the
country's value itself and even with
such kind of a small amount of time
series and the neural network models you
able to extra extrapolate into the
future fairly well so the question
naturally arises how can we combine the
best of both worlds
statistic model imposed stronger
assumptions about data generating
process as such they enjoy the benefits
such as data efficiency to probability
and so on and so forth
such advantages especially prominent in
a situation of the limited amount of
data points on the other hand the
expressiveness of neural networks are
not done to reach into the statistic
tails of each time series aggregate them
and amplify them so that we can transfer
the statistical strength from time
series with richer history to the wines
we limit it to no information at all
so naturally we just want to combine the
strengths of both approaches so that we
can have models and elegantly scale from
this more data regime to big data regime
so how can we do this the same with a
lot of other things in machine learning
or artificial intelligences - joy
inspirations from the standard statistic
models so in particular the statistical
techniques that we are that we are
seeking is from the two old ideas from
multitask learning on the left-hand side
the two main ideas from left on the
left-hand side this is the idea of
multitask nore
basically what it means is that for each
of the time series we assume that there
is the underlying model but generating
all those time series but under all the
parameters they are shared somehow how
do they share the parameters we assume
there is a hierarchical model that will
generate all the parameters for those
answers here is an example of this well
the simplest case which is multitask
manual regression as you can see each
time series is assumed to be generated
from a bigger model and the weight
vector of the linear model is jointly
generated by multivariate all tossing on
the right hand side another way to
multitask learning in through the models
called mixed effect models the mixed
effects models the model assumption is
that for you show the cam series I would
consist of a fixed effect basically
capture the assured pattern of autumn
series and a random effect that is very
specific to this time series and in the
simplest case you can think of the time
series fanners is from an additive model
and combining the fading the fixed
effect and random effect plus some
random noise again here is another
example example with an in-ear mixed
effects models were the most fixed
effect and random effect come from
linear models so in the next couple of
slides we'll talk about how we used
those two old ideas to combine classical
time series models and neural networks
in particular we'll be talking about
deep space based model which is a
combination of state space model and
neural networks and the factor model
which combines the dynamic factor model
with neural networks in the framework of
mixed effects models so the key idea of
both approaches is incorporating
structure so let next let's pipe into
the deep space space model but before
moving forward
let's start simple let's start with a
simple exponential smoothing model that
monos her time series behavior so for
the simple state space simple
exponential smoothing model the
prediction is the weighted average of
all observations you can write the
formula as follows so Z to the
prediction at time 2 would be a linear
combination of yesterday's shoe value
and yesterday's prediction and in a
similar manner the prediction at day 3
would be collinear
combination of date whose observation
they was observation and a prediction
from day one and initial predictions and
the Smoothie parameters are adjustable
parameters so essentially the simple
exponential smoothing and the main mean
tells it's a weighted average of all
observations and here you can see an
example of simple explanation of
smoothing model things it's the simple
simple model without any seasonality
factor as you can see you will be just
the average of previous observations so
let's see how how to generalize simple
exponential smoothing into a framework
that allows us to have more flexible
modeling choice the same equation as
before the prediction at t plus 1 will
be a linear combination of the previous
forecast and the error in the previous
forecast
and we can we can think the process is
the following we use the latent variable
LTE to represent a little of the time
series and we assume such animated
variable changes every day
and with this framework as we can see we
can rewrite a simple expansion smoothing
model with two equations one is the
error correction term where basically
describes how this latent variable will
behave this latent variable yes today's
dated variable will be yesterday's
latent variable plus the correction term
from yesterday's prediction and the
forecast equation is very simple is
basically equal to the same latent
variable and here you can see a
graphical profit or representation of
such kind of process and to generate the
forecast into the future or to see how
this timing process works basically you
start with L 0 which is the initial
condition and you generate the forecast
of the next day and then the latent
variable equal to the next day and then
generate the forecast or of the day
afterwards and so on and so forth so ok
so this is the same simple exponential
smoothing model just written in another
format and then just for pranker same as
before see exponential smoothing
smoothing parameter alpha and the
initial level which is 0 of course this
latent variable
consists more than just a level here in
the one step ahead extension the latent
variable itself would be a re
representing for the unobserved fans for
example level train and differences
seasonal effects and error correction
term again we add more flexibility which
means that today's error correction will
be today's latent variable would be
yesterday's like a marital Club and cut
and go through a linear transformation
and multiplies the correction term with
some other parameter and the forecast
equation would be an in-ear combination
of the latent variable itself and all
the parameters depends on the panels be
modeled and and the state space
parameters can be learned from the data
the advantage of having such kind of a
statistic model of the of the data
generation process is it produces an
entire probability distribution for
future time period and which makes the
easier to compute prediction intervals
with a keep given evolve confidence this
can be put into a state-space model
framework where the error correction
term would be replaced by stage
foundation where in general governments
how the latent variable involves and the
moments in this linear Leighton space
model state space model will be a linear
combination of latent state plus some
noise term here the equation by itself
is actually a special kind of state
space model which is called innovation
space based model where the error term
of the measurements at stage Foundation
are shared but in general you can have
two different source of error the
generative process would be exactly same
as before we start as an initial latent
variable estimate which generates the
January to October issue and the latest
ad evolves and generate another
observation and so on and so forth so
this generating process looks very
similar to what what you've seen in the
previous orange section the only
difference is that unlike RN where the
states foundation is deterministic here
this the state transition is random
if by allowing the random state
transition you will be able to add
information and each of the stage
through the noise propagation so getting
that printer is the initial condition
the space based model parameter and the
noise variance okay so now that we've
give a recap of what's the state space
model is let's describe what deep state
space model is as previous mentioning in
this idea of hierarchical Bayesian or
multi task learning framework the basic
assumption is each of the countries is
generated by some model
and the prime source of all those maldo
shared the same prior
in this case all of the time series is
generated by a state-space model and the
prior of the parameter of the space
based model is given by RNA itself so
the prior itself is actually
deterministic so in Britain in essence
there is an RN that generates the space
based model parameter for all of the
time series and conditional the prompter
of each of the time series we use a
state space model to generate the whole
sequence
so how does the training look like so
here for the training the semis any of
the standard are we feeding a sequence
of features exogenous variables such as
set dates feature an example would be
day of the week week of the year or
other type of features such as
temperature or or some other weather
information you feed all those
information into an RN and this week on
your network will give you the parameter
and each step for the state space model
and based on those parameter you can
generate your own provisions that would
be that that will be the data generating
process the loss will be delectable lot
likelihood under our model under our
model assumption so to calculate the
liquid for not likelihood requires to
the inference in the standard sense but
luckily we already have efficient the
inference algorithm in such men of the
America linear state-space models which
is common future
notice that by capturing stochasticity
as a part of the model assumption there
is no need to feed him back into in this
Auto regressive observation in this way
the model is more robust to know and
outliers and it keeps because of his
probabilistic model it can in transit
clear under emission data here principle
way
so just to recap the deep state space
model combines the neural network model
and state space model by using a new
reference model your network models to
generate the parameter of the state
space model and conditioned on all those
states based models parameter to
generate all the operations so next time
we're going to talk about another way to
explore structure
the another this way of the exploring
structure is to combine in the local
model and global model
so just to recap the look by my local
model we mean that there's models to
model each country's locally and
individually normally there will be
simple models like expression of
smoothing ARIMA model they're very
simple the accuracies in the present in
the regime of large fraction countries
are a relatively low and it's very hard
to do model selection once you have a
large fraction of answers on the other
hand for the global model such as
standard neural network models or dpr
and other related models you can model
answer is globally and jointly into a
resulting higher a model of higher
accuracy but also means that is more
complex and needs a lot of data and to
make your work
the model that combines both a no-fun
global approach is super deep factor
model so i'll repeating of defector
models is to combine the local model and
global model in such a way so you'd for
the local model it's used to model per
item behavior per time sears behavior
and he reads and syncs from the global
model and the updates local state based
on the easting made of the global model
and the global model on the other hand
model the shared behavior across all the
countries and it's a nonlinear backbone
as a matter of fact a simple color array
of definitive theorem assure that this
is actually a natural representation
when you have an exchangeable
distribution over eight connection
countries and what do I mean by that an
exchangeable distribution over a
correction time series means that if you
shuffle around of this functional time
series the joint distribution still
remains the same so basically this
theorem Amir says that the Joint
Distribution
other such panels are circumstances
Joint Distribution can be written as a
local and global formation here the G is
a global model and conditioned on G you
can model / cancerous behavior
individually so beta is all based on
this observation the defector tried to
combine the fixed trying to combine the
global model and the local model in the
framework of a mixed effects model in
particular each time series is assumed
to be generated by a combination of
fixed effects and a random effect and a
random fixed effect itself by borrowing
the idea of dynamic factor model which
he can be think I think has
extension of principal component
analysis is that each time and global
country's global part is a linear
combination of K latent factors and all
those latent factors is generated by our
ends
that's our nonlinear background and the
random effect models captures
uncertainty captures the local
fluctuations and there is different type
of random effect model that you can
choose here you can specify two popular
models will be States based models and
Gaussian processes and once you have the
global effect and a random effect then
you can combine them either with
additive or multiplicative to generative
lately they can function and from the
later function you will have an emission
probability to generate the time series
itself notice that for the fixed effect
we are using equals means that this is
deterministic and it's nonlinear
backbone and deterministic and for the
random effect is actually stochastic
come from a probabilistic model so it
has been shown that by combining the
neural networks and either space based
model and Gaussian process model in the
framework of a factor and it results in
better sample complexity at least
empirically which means that it requires
less number of countries and the less
number of data points for countries to
be able to achieve certain performance
in the predictive range and it also
results in more parsimonious
representation of the model which would
enables faster inference notice that
those type of ideas of having a global
part for the global part the capture the
shared pattern
and the local parts that only
specifically capture the individual
pattern such kind of modeling tech
techniques goes beyond plain
timeseriesforecasting as well for
example in here in the context of a ploy
process you can also use such kind of
techniques where you can model the
conditional intensity function using a
global part which is the RF battle save
RM backbone as a defector and the local
part instead of using instead of using
the Gaussian process or space a space
based model in the classical countries
domain in carrying point process you can
use a hoax process as a local model the
same story as the factor by enforcing
structures you would achieve the
efficiency and here in particular it
accelerates learning and accelerates
inference and also result in more plus
ammonius model so that you get less
number of parameters just to summarize
the approach is that the models of deep
space model deep space based model and
de facto model from the modeling
perspective it mirrors the hierarchical
Bayesian and mixed effects model and for
the inference for the Gaussian
likelihood you can use very efficient
inference method for the space based
models use a common filter and for the D
factor models with with Gaussian process
you can use the exactly inference or any
of the approximate inference techniques
that have been developed that in the
last two decades for other likelihood
models for both models you can use
variational inference where you
introduce where you introduce a
recognition network that generate
Gaussian approximations and condition
costing approximations
the inference noise down to the first
first case to summarize the advantage
and disadvantages the approaches of
combining and deep neural networks and
the classical time series models allows
for some stronger model assumption so it
works very well in limited data regime
and is also possible yes and so that is
resulting faster training and most
stable model and in in theory because we
you ask the stochasticity intrinsic to
the model you get better uncertainty
model in theory and but the but the
disadvantage is that because of the
complexity that introduced it's more
complicated to implement and so that is
more prone to numerical errors for
example implementing common filter or
the any of the
the Gaussian process inference mechanism
and for the state-space models it's more
involved to design seasonality factor
and for the Gaussian process the design
of the kernels is also something that
you have to think about with that I
conclude the part of the deep
probabilistic model and a fan of the
part two next part to my colleague Kim
Yamazaki who is going to talk about the
practical aspects of the forecasting of
the big cancers thank you